Plaiting or plating is a technique that
uses two strands of yarn held together.
The machine positions the yarn in such
a way that the strands are knitted
together at the same time,
but one strand shows on the purl side,
the other strand shows on the knit side.
Keep in mind that you're knitting two
strands together, so you'll want to use
a finer yarn than you might
normally use on your machine.
Also, mixing weights and textures of yarn
can produce very interesting
plaiting results.
In this plaiting example,
the teal is showing on the purl side and
the white is showing on the knit side.
Think of the possibilities of having
reversible fabric, color wise.
Without using a plaiting yarn feeder.
The yarns would normally twist
and the colors would randomly be
shown on each side of the knitting.
To knit in plaiting on Brother standard
gauge machines,
we need to replace the yarn feeder
assembly that's in the sinker plate.
Remove the sinker plate from the machine.
Loosen and remove the screws
holding the assembly.
If they're tight, use a screwdriver
or a coin to loosen them.
With the screws removed,
carefully slip the yarn feeder out
and insert the plating feeder
and secure it with the screws.
To thread the feeder,
snap one yarn into the back slot
and insert the other
strand in the front slot.
The feeder positions the yarns so they
align in a way that one strand is held
in front and shows on the purl side.
The other strand shows on the knit side.
Plaiting can also be done with the ribber
using a ribber plaiting attachment.
Don't forget, since you're knitting
with two strands, you'll need to use finer
yarn than you might normally knit with.